measurement into non-destructive measurement simply by considering the implementation of this measurement that we discussed in the context of Neymar's
theorem we introduce a new system y interact it with X through a unitary operation U and then perform a standard
basis measurement on y so the system X is still there and we can consider its
state and based on the analysis that we went through we can determine that the postmeasurement state of X conditioned
on getting a particular measurement outcome a is given by a density Matrix that looks like
this in words we conjugate by the square root of the corresponding measurement Matrix and then
normalize another way to formulate non-destructive measurements which is more General is in terms of cross
matrices of channels and this is the definition of measurements you'll find in the well-known textbook of Neil in
Trang for instance suppose that m0 through m m minus1 are square matrices that satisfy
the equation that's shown on the screen which is to say that we could think about these matrices as being cross matrices that describe a
channel in fact these matrices do describe a channel but they also describe a non-destructive measurement
and the way that it works when a system in a given State row is measured is first the outcome probabilities are
given by the equation shown on the screen each outcome appears with probability equal to the trace of ma *
row * ma dagger and conditioned on the alcome a appearing the state of the measured
system looks like this non-destructive measurements of this sort can be implemented in a
similar way to what we had for Neymar's theorem and I'll leave that for you to think about if you
choose it is possible to generalize the concept of a non-destructive measurement even further than this for example
there's a concept of a so-called Quantum instrument that's sometimes quite useful but I won't cover that in this
video in the last part of the lesson I'll briefly discuss two tasks that are associated with measurements Quantum State discrimination and Quantum State
tomography there's quite a lot to be said about both of these Concepts and we're really just going to be scratching the
surface so let's start by clarifying what these terms refer to and how they differ
first is quantum State discrimination the idea here is that we have a known collection of quantum
states of some system along with probabilities associated with these states so to be precise let's assume
that row 0 through row M minus1 are density matrices representing possible Quantum states of a system X and p 0
through PN minus one are probabilities associated with these states so if we collect the probabilities into a single
Vector we get a ability Vector a succinct way of saying this by the way is that we have an ensemble of quantum
States and now an abstract way that we can think about Quantum State discrimination as a task or as a problem
is that first a number between Z and N minus one is chosen randomly according to the probabilities the system X is then
prepared in the state corresponding to the randomly selected number and the goal is to determine by
means of a measurement of X which number was chosen so we have a finite number of
Alternatives along with a prior and the goal is to determine which alternative actually happened for some choices of states and
probabilities this may be easy and for others it may not be possible to do this without some chance of making an error
and there are various specific questions that we could ask such as what is the minimum probability of making an error
and what does a measurement that achieves this minimum probability of error look like Quantum State tomography on the
other hand is different here we have an unknown Quantum state of a system so there's
typically no prior or any information about possible Alternatives this time however it's not a single copy of the state that's made
available but rather many independent copies are made available which is to say that for some possibly large number
n we have n identical systems X1 through xn that are each independently prepared in the state
row and this time the goal is to find an approximation of this unknown Quantum State as a density matrix by measuring
the systems so in summary in Quantum State discrimination we have a single copy of
the state and we're trying to discriminate among a finite number of known Alternatives and in Quantum State demography we have many independent
copies of an unknown Quantum State and the goal is to find a description of that state or at least a decent approximation of
it quantum State discrimination is interesting because it abstracts a type of situation that commonly arises in
computation and cryptography for instance where one alternative out of a finite set of possibilities has taken place and we or somebody else is trying
to figure out which one it was by measuring a Quantum system the simplest non-trivial case is
where there are just two Alternatives meaning that m is equal to two so the task is to discriminate between a pair
of States this case turns out to be essentially a completely solid problem assuming that the goal is to minimize
the chance of an incorrect discrimination there's an optimal choice for a measurement and it's often called
the hellstrom measurement it's a projective measurement in fact and it can be described as
follows first we consider the weighted difference between the two Alternatives meaning p 0 * row 0 minus P1 * Row one
so we're multiplying the probability of drawing each of these two states to the states themselves and we're taking the
difference that's a herian matrix because it equals its own conjugate transpose so it has a spectral
decomposition and we know in particular that the igen values are all real numbers so let's assume that we have a
spectral decomposition written in the form that's shown on the screen what we do next is to collect the
igen values into two sets where all of the positive IG values are in one set and all of the negative IG values are in
the other to be precise let's take s0 to be the set of all the indices k for which the corresponding igen value Lambda K is
non- negative and let S1 be the remaining indices which are the ones corresponding to negative IG
values it doesn't actually matter which set contains the indices corresponding to any zero I values here we're making
an arbitrary choice to include the minus zero but it wouldn't make any difference if some or all of them were included in S1 instead all that really matters is
that we're separating the positive and negative IG values and finally we Define two projections Pi
0 and Pi 1 as is shown on the screen in words Pi 0 is the projection onto the